vous déjà karl vous organiser des
soirées les soirées à 200 personnes et
je vous n'étiez vous n'êtes jamais fait
prendre
alors ça m'est arrivé de l'organiser
mais gba principalement un titre en tant
que parent c'est bon d'accord et il y a
et en appelant sa à paris le week-end
ouais ça nous est arrivé d'avoir des
policiers qui dans l'aisne qui met fin à
la fête mais c'est pas deux sur le cac
vous pensez qu'il faut pas sanctionner
les restaurants clandestins des fêtes
monde estime je pense que là on arrive à
un stade à hasnon après ou au tournoi
les jeunes adultes
nous dirigeants qu'on en a marre vous
voyez vous voyez qu'un nouveau variant
qui arrive si fabrice division nous dit
qu'il faut pas s'en méfier le variant
brésilien quand vous entendez des choses
comme ça vous dit on s'en fout de cas
des variants ouais non mais voilà de
tout ça on continue ce soir et continua
à se réunir à 200 à 300 personnes c'est
pas qu'on se fout mais à la nuit et sans
risque si demain au ca red devils parce
qu'il ya parce qu'il ya un tel virus ou
un tel cas où un terreau variantes
telles qu évident on ne dit plus haut ce
soir on vit malgré le fait que qui est
des variantes qu'il a les clés de la
combine
c'est le jeu ono au sort un accepte de
sortir parce qu'on veut c'est que malgré
tout c'est que tu intérêts police et les
amandes avec nos paroles et les amendes
et qu'on est à verbaliser mais ce jeu
alors que steevy question pour toi tu
fonces car le moins cher outré par ce
que j'entendais enfin moi j'ai pas eue
il ya des gens autour de moi qui se
consomme morts de cette maladie
on essaye de tous faire des efforts de
respecter les règles qu'est ce que c'est
que respecter les règles pendant un an
il ya quand même deux anciens ils ont
quand même vécu eu la guerre des choses
beaucoup plus graves
beaucoup plus graves qu'une maladie on
l'a on doit juste faire un effort pour
pouvoir s'en sortir on n'a pas les n'a
pas les bonbons n'a pas tout ça doit
quand même je trouve ça profondément et
respect et irrespectueux